[inaudible].
All right,
well we'll kick it off.
My name is Malique goop marred.
I am a director of content partnerships,
um,
at,
at Youtube and,
um,
it's such a great honor to,
to have the,
the cast and the producers from 12 years a slave directed by Steve McQueen.
True,
true to his honor.
We have with us here today.
Julie,
tell Eduphoria who plays the,
the title character Solomon Northrop.
Lupita Nyong'o who plays Patsy Alfre Woodard,
who plays mistress Shaw,
um,
a DD Gardner and Jeremy Kleiner from plan B who are producers on the film.
So,
so thanks again and welcome to to Google Los Angeles.
Um,
and we,
we know that it's a very,
very busy time.
It's award season,
lots of red carpets and we wanted to also start with congratulating you for the,
the Golden Globe for best drama.
So deserve it.
And uh,
none of them
actually have a question.
The,
is that,
that actual Golden Globe and,
and is it made out of gold?
Would love to one day holding.
Uh,
we'd love to kick it off with a quick short trailer,
um,
from,
from the film to tee things up.
So
Solomon,
if you want to sit her,
say as little as possible.
There is no jurisdiction this slavery pleases with the property.
I did as instructed.
There's something wrong.
It's wrong with the instruction
is up
12 years a slave.
I was a funny man.
Talk about the story behind the story.
Like I think that that it's fascinating,
um,
for from a couple of different,
you know,
stand points.
It doesn't seem like it's like the very first movie on Hollywood's list to Megan
and thank God that you guys created the movie.
Buckin you know,
maybe you start with the producers,
you know,
Dee Dee Dee and Jeremy Can,
can you tell us the story behind the story is around the creation of the movie?
Sure.
We met with Steve Mcqueen five years ago.
We saw hunger before it even premiered in Toronto and were blown away when we
asked to sit down with them and have a meeting and say,
we think you're amazing.
And we'd like to try and find something to do with you.
He said,
well,
what does that mean?
Um,
but it evolved into a conversation about things that matter to us.
And he asked us a really questions to why do you think it is that no American
film has really addressed the institution of slavery the day in,
day out experience of what that decades and decades long era of American history
was.
And we said,
we didn't know,
um,
with humility and some distress.
And we said,
why don't we try?
And that was,
uh,
that was honestly the very,
very beginning,
right,
that
picking up from that point,
um,
and Steve had very clear ideas about certain elements.
Um,
the screenwriter,
John Ridley became involved in the project at a certain point in the process.
Steve's partner,
Bianca found or came across because it existed,
but came across this incredible book,
Sama Northrop's memoir,
which I would encourage everyone if you have an opportunity to read this piece
of material.
Uh,
it's an incredible,
uh,
overwhelming,
devastating,
a heartbreaking story.
And that became the basis of what we then turned into a screenplay that got us
to starting to shoot the movie in June of 2012.
It was a fairly quick process after the recognition that the manuscript was the
basis of the movie that Steve had in his mind.
That's fantastic.
And,
um,
yeah,
I,
I hadn't heard of the story.
I'm sure many of us hadn't heard of it before,
before you brought it up.
Um,
I even took a African studies,
African American studies classes in college.
My mom came of age in civil rights or in Harlem in the 60s,
and none of us heard you guys found this,
this great,
great materials.
And thank you.
Um,
I do want to ask a question for the Peta.
your portrayal of,
of Patsy,
um,
was,
was so strong,
was so truthful,
um,
and you,
you've gone on,
you know,
an amazing ride.
You came out of Yale drama school,
um,
not,
not that long ago.
And,
and now you're on red carpets and an awards and,
and what,
what's your journey been like?
Oh my,
it's been,
it's been an adventure.
It's been,
um,
it's been a lot,
uh,
you know,
it all started with Steve calling me to offer me this pot.
And that in itself was a life changing experience,
having the opportunity to,
um,
embody such a phenomenal woman that Solomon Northup described as having an air
of loftiness.
The neither labor nor lash could rid her off.
I mean,
I,
it was such a privilege and I thoroughly,
thoroughly enjoyed playing patsy and,
and then,
um,
there was this long wait and then the press begun and uh,
you ready for what's about to happen?
And my answer was always no,
I have no idea what's about to happen.
But know I was surrounded by people who've been through it before and who have
been so,
so supportive of me from the very beginning.
So I've never felt alone or panicked as such.
Cause I've had,
I've had a backup.
So it's been,
it's been a long fine and I'm just so happy for how this film has been received.
It's not easy subject matter,
but the fact that people are embracing it,
the way they have an engaging with it is very exciting.
Can you tell us about the call that you got when you were offered the role?
Um,
I've,
I've read or heard or saw that you weren't sure,
you pause,
you had to,
you had to think about it and,
um,
what,
what drew you to the role,
but,
but also what would frightened you or scared you were about to?
Yeah,
I was quite intimidated by it actually in the end when I,
when Steve called me,
you know,
I'd done,
I actually like dd,
I've known Steve for,
um,
for a while,
ever since hunger,
I went out just to Amsterdam to away lives,
to have a coffee with them and just walk and talk about film and about life.
And,
um,
and I,
and I'd want it to work with them and we wanted to try and find something to do
together.
And so I was excited to get to get the call,
you know,
that he had this project that he wanted me to look at it and I,
uh,
so he sent it to me and you know,
obviously I was stunned by the story.
Like everybody else.
I'd never heard of fellow in north.
I've never heard of this story.
I'd never seen a film from inside this experience inside the slave experience.
I,
I kind of concluded they wouldn't,
they wouldn't be one somehow that,
uh,
the received information was always that it's impossible to do,
you know,
that,
uh,
that you need to approach this material from a kind of oblique angle.
You can't just have a,
a story that talks about the experience from somebody who was inside the
experience from us,
the perspective of a slave themselves,
you know?
Uh,
so,
um,
I'd kind of,
uh,
in a weird way accepted that.
And um,
and so when I read the,
when I read the screenplay,
I didn't even see Allaman really in it the first time I saw it as a story of
somebody,
a man who went through this kind of extraordinary experience.
And I remember feeling the weight of that.
And I looked at the story and I looked at his journey in the context of like the
wider conversations about race by race,
politics about slavery,
about making films,
about slavery,
about the,
the,
the pressure,
uh,
the responsibility.
Uh,
and you know,
all of those things kind of intimidated me and I didn't want to be the guy at
the center of something that in the end wasn't what I wanted it to be because I
somehow had let it down.
Right.
Uh,
I felt that because Solomon was in every scene and every sequence of the film
that the,
um,
that I had to be absolutely sure that I could get to all those places.
In the end of course,
I realized that,
that I was thinking with the completely the wrong part of my hand,
you know,
and um,
uh,
when I was,
Steve was quite surprised by my initial reaction.
And so I went back anyway to,
to read the book.
And as I was looking at the book,
I realized that course,
the,
that was the point.
The point wasn't that I had to worry about any of those things.
You know,
there was a,
there was something in the way that the book is written and the way Sullivan
talks about his story that you really is,
we realized that this is a sober reflection on a man's life over this period of
time.
And he writes about it with such a,
such poetry with such humility was such a kind of understanding of the human
experience,
the human spirit,
a kind of three dimensional reality,
the way he talks about all the other people in the,
in the story,
um,
with and given them the Jew,
giving them the respect that we know two dimensional,
one dimensional characters.
He got to know all these people very well and talks about them as,
as human beings.
And it becomes that very beautiful thing of a,
of a first person,
historical narrative that sends you right back into a time and place,
a primary source.
And,
um,
and I guess at that point I realized that I was connecting with that and I
didn't have to worry about the kind of,
the historical geo political race,
politics of everything.
And all of that was kind of nonsensical and I don't know why I went down that
path in the first place,
but I did.
And,
uh,
and of course,
at that point when I realized I just,
my,
my responsibility,
my job was to tell Solomon story as best I could.
Yeah.
Then I was at,
within my,
called Steve and apologized.
And yeah,
there's,
there's something that,
um,
you know,
the,
the film is about African slavery in America.
Um,
but,
but it also seems like it's,
it's this,
you know,
wider canvas that,
that you,
that the team,
that,
uh,
um,
you know,
creators,
you painted,
you know,
it's,
you,
you tell the story of the horrors of slavery that the triumph over it.
Um,
but it also seems to be about the overcoming of oppression just in the world in
general.
Um,
you know,
the Holocaust crimes against women,
human trafficking.
Um,
today,
what was this,
was this film also a call to action or a reminder,
um,
to,
to look at what's right under our noses in,
in 2014
there's a,
a shot,
uh,
Solomon
and I,
I'm forgetting when it comes,
but he turns,
he's gazing out and then he turns and looks directly into the camera directly at
the audience.
And Steve has said that he meant to,
to,
to drive home the point of when Solomon looks out at us,
it's on you.
Yes,
this is,
this is a historical treatment,
but what are you going to do with what you're seeing?
So that's,
that's,
that was an intentional shot there.
Yeah.
It's a story about engaging with what we want human respect means.
And I think that's what the book was about.
Um,
that's,
I think that the essential part of what Solomon was talking about
is,
is human respect and human dignity.
And that is something that,
of course can be applied to.
So our age,
a very directly to every,
to every age.
And,
uh,
that's why that's the fundamentally the relevance,
I think.
Yeah.
There's also,
um,
spoke to it,
a lot of,
we could crowd source a lot of these questions and um,
that seems to be something like almost,
um,
uh,
oddly familiar and accessible,
um,
about the film.
Um,
you know,
Solomon is a guy who lives in the city,
we live in the city.
He,
he's got,
you know,
a family and kids.
I have family and kids.
He's got an opportunity to,
to help his family and then we've all been there.
Um,
and then everything suddenly changes.
it was almost an,
I don't want to read into it,
but it felt like you were,
um,
putting,
putting an on ramp for us,
no matter what race,
no matter where you come from an onramp into,
um,
you're free.
But here,
here's,
here's how this other experience has,
has been [inaudible] was that,
was that by,
by design?
I think that stuff is in the story,
right?
I mean as it happens that relate-ability uh,
I think that it's right though that Steve understood that those elements made
the story,
uh,
accessible.
And,
and he's talked about it at times as it's obviously based on a real person,
but he's talked about it as almost like a fable are something that has for all
of its complexity,
its,
its richness.
It's its three dimensionality.
There's also an element of like a universal language quality of it that,
that anybody can understand.
And I think that that as a filmmaker,
I think he very astutely understood that,
that,
that allowed people to access this.
And,
um,
as,
as Lupita said,
you know,
one of the great aspects of this experience has been the public's receptivity
and,
and embracing of this movie,
uh,
for all,
as she would tell,
said the conventional wisdom about,
you know,
what is acceptable,
what isn't and what will people access of what will they not access.
Right.
I'm just going to say also,
uh,
when we have seen some really good attempts at Ed,
looking at darkly at a period during slavery,
we could always sort of look at a distance.
We be emotional about it,
but you could,
there was a distance there and that's exactly what Solomon's story,
uh,
gay is the gift of it is that we go in with him and,
and that's why people have such a visceral reaction to it.
Go on the journey.
And so,
you know,
of course people have talked about,
how brutal it is,
uh,
as well as beautiful.
But again,
I think Steve has said there's,
there's only five,
maybe six,
six instances actually of violence in it.
When you think of what watched today just on TV with all of the crime scene
investigations,
all those kinds of things,
what are,
what are teenagers are used to seeing happen to heads and things on screen that
it really isn't,
but what,
why it hits us so hard is how successful it is at bringing us in.
We go in,
as you say,
down the rabbit hole with,
with solid,
right,
right.
Take,
Massey could a lot of manage his own time,
manage them all the cursor to Pharaoh's power sample,
a lot white plantation class.
This is nice.
So Alfre
portray,
um,
another type of southern women that um,
history doesn't tell that story too often.
Um,
you,
you were once a slave but you're now,
um,
or your characters,
a plantation owners,
um,
wife and therefore also a slave owner herself and she's got this almost surreal
sense of esteem that Patsy's,
um,
character,
uh,
connects to and they have this really interesting relationship and their lives
are so different.
We would love to,
to hear more about what,
what that relationship was and,
and what,
um,
each Scott out of it.
Well I think
what Lupita said about patsy having the air of loftiness,
I think Mr is Shah.
They say way is apps and everybody else,
she is an exceptional person.
Patsy is,
and it doesn't matter what station you put a person like that in that is still
going to come from them.
There are women in that house.
Ms. Mr [inaudible] is not getting invited to tea parties at the other
plantations.
But there are certainly women in every plantation house.
There's lots of women.
Concubines,
you know,
just,
that's,
that's how life was.
So there are people in her house that she could have tea with,
but this person has shown this incredible sense of,
of,
of character and you're drawn to her.
So she recognizes that in patsy.
That's why I think she likes spending time with patsy because it makes her
special.
One thing that Mr [inaudible] has to do what she has to constantly try to feel
special because she knows how to do the form of I'm I have arrived.
Uh,
that's why she forces Plat to sit with her is that she knows and everybody in
the area knows that he knows more words then her husband and all the other
masters.
Right.
And so,
but it is so self centered.
It doesn't matter what's going on with him,
what's going to happen when he gets back.
Let's have tea.
So she has created her own little elite circle there.
Those are the people,
she wants to sit with it.
But at the same time,
she is trying to get patsy to use her,
her attraction to,
to elevate her state in life.
And,
and of course he doesn't do it,
which makes her even wore a person to be admired and drawn to.
So I think that's the basis basis of how she,
what she wants from that relationship.
And Lupita,
I'm curious,
you know,
the,
um,
the scenery,
the environment of,
of this movie in Louisiana was,
was so,
so rich and Steve's um,
sort of bringing out the beautiful icons and imagery of the south of the
plantations,
the cotton fields that the weeping willows.
Um,
I must've,
I imagine it must've been like living in,
in,
in history and you're very real presence as well.
W W what was it like being on set,
but it also being in that history,
I mean,
it was so useful.
I can't imagine this film being shot any other place because the history is so
present in Louisiana.
The oak trees that were surrounding us were like 300 years old.
So they witnessed people like Solomon and patsy and you know,
they,
they'll probably black people who would hang from those trees and,
and um,
so it was always very present and also the heat is a character.
I,
you know,
you,
you prepare,
I was preparing him Massachusetts and not in Massachusetts and Connecticut or
this role where I was living and um,
you know,
and then you get down to Louisiana and everything changes in the heat.
Your priorities change.
You know,
I really have to walk that fine.
Do I need that sound rich right now?
So
hot and um,
you,
so it changed my gate,
itch it,
it just,
it took me that extra mile into character to think about the fact that these
were the conditions that the slaves were working under.
They were picking cotton for how many hours in these conditions.
Our first day on set was 108 degrees and we wish shooting the cotton picking
season.
So,
you know,
and it's back breaking work as well to bend over and you have to have a plan.
If you're going to pick 500 pounds of cotton a day,
there's got to be a system in place.
And so it was all so helpful.
And I remember the first time I put on like my costume,
Patty Norris,
the costume designer,
she said to me that my clothes were from an actual sleep.
It was actual sleeve woman's garb.
And I looked down at it,
had these intricate patchwork on the,
on the skirt and I was just met with the fact that every single stitch on this
good story and I was standing in it to you though.
And yeah,
I mean all those things helped so much with getting into character.
Right,
right.
So,
uh,
another,
another clip.
Oh,
went domestic Charles Plantation.
You admit it freely and you know why I got this from Mr Schulte.
Ms Is not shown even grab me know,
so
thank you so much.
I make myself gay.
Day In,
day out is modern,
any Madea and food out,
be clean.
That's what I did here.
What?
I went to Charlottesville
and then we know where we're,
the seam goes after that.
Okay.
Can,
can you tell us how did you prepare for,
for that,
um,
specific scene that,
that day?
Um,
you know,
pro probably,
I guess one of the hardest days and Patsy's life and I'm sure a hard day in your
life as well.
Yeah.
And the book Solomon Describes a day as one of the darkest days of all times.
And that is significant considering how much violence there was on this
plantation.
He talks about hearing the crack of a whip from dawn to dusk on this plantation.
So he was always something that I was aware it was coming.
But in preparing for Patsy,
patsy always had an undercurrent of grief because that was a condition of her
life.
But I couldn't sentimentalize one day from another states work for me.
It was,
I,
it was just making it practical that that was what I was going to have to do on
Tuesday.
No,
but,
uh,
the day before,
we did a scene in which I needed the wounds from,
uh,
from previous,
with things patty has previous with things before that one.
And we,
we,
we had,
um,
those put on my back and it took four hours.
And so the next day for the next day,
I was looking at the call sheet and I saw that I was going to be in the makeup
chair for six hours to do the pre whipping and then the post whipping scarves.
And uh,
I said to the makeup artists Color Davey,
listen,
I'm just going to go home with these guys so that tomorrow we can cut my w I
work in half.
And she loved the idea.
So I went back to my hotel room and,
and I tried to get some sleep.
Uh,
I had a very hard time sleeping the entire time that I was,
we were making 12 years a slave.
But that night I slept even less because these guys would just ever so present
on my back.
And I was uncomfortable.
I stepped on my belly and I just,
I was just haunted by these things on my back.
And I remember weeping at night and I was fretting to myself.
And then it occurred to me that my discomfort was temporary and the woman whom I
was so privileged to portray her discomfort was permanent.
And it just puts everything into perspective for the next day.
And it was that one thing I needed in preparation for the next day that I could
not have planned,
you know,
but it just really centered me and gave me just presence of mind for the next
day's work because there was absolutely no other way that I could prepare for
the humiliation and the Sh,
just the heartbreak of being stripped naked and,
and,
and whipped.
So anyway,
the next day I got on set.
And what I found is that was everyone's so focused on the work at hand,
so I wasn't going in it by myself.
You know,
I was going in with my,
my cast members to a towel,
Michael Cera,
and we all needed each other to make it happen.
I mean,
it was,
um,
our responsibility to just do,
do the scene as,
as honestly and openly as we could.
And,
um,
I remember,
I,
it was heartbreaking,
but it was such a joy to be able to go there as well.
It was amazing.
Um,
and I have to imagine that it's going back and forth between that real history
and then your real life were,
you know,
one moment,
apps,
these apps,
and then in the next moment he's Michael,
um,
uh,
dismiss have been jarring.
Um,
yeah.
Yeah.
It wasn't actually,
I don't think it was ever Jari we all recognize that it will do this.
It was our job to do these,
to play these roles.
And my goal would have been,
it would have done his us a disservice if he was any gentler,
you know,
he went there full force at Lee and he was so scary.
Um,
but it was exciting to be able to work with someone who was that committed and,
and to do it with people that you trust and,
and gained extra respect for and love because of their commitment to their
roles.
I,
it never was jarring to me.
No.
What was it like working with Steve Mcqueen?
Uh,
uh,
you were quoted as saying he's making films that people will be talking about
and watching 50 years from now.
Um,
tell us more about the style and this is also enough to,
to,
to anyone who would love to hear more.
Um,
Steve,
you know,
is,
uh,
I just,
I mean from everything that I've seen of his from before,
you know,
from hunger shame,
he just has an exceptional autistic quality.
I mean,
he's really a true,
I mean obviously he has an autistic background,
but he's somebody who,
who's involved in every aspect of filmmaking in a way that I do think is,
is rare that he is,
um,
that he just seems so,
so born to it and a,
and has this kind of depth of,
of passion that matches his ability.
Uh,
and it means that you feel completely in safe hands in any,
in whatever he asks you to do.
And wherever he is asking you to push whatever avenue you're going to go down,
you'll never feeling that you can.
Um,
you know,
you want to keep one foot on the dock and one on the boat.
You know,
you are,
you're free just to get in the boat and sail away with them,
you know,
and uh,
and see whatever,
whatever comes out of that.
You know,
I,
um,
you know,
I've never shot a film in sequence and I remember that in the first early on I
spoke to Steve about maybe shooting this in sequence,
you know,
um,
and uh,
and he said he liked the idea but that because of people's schedules,
you know,
um,
uh,
it just wasn't possible.
So we had to shoot certain bits in it in different.
Uh,
so we started on the apps plantation actually.
And,
uh,
and so in a way that was very good for me because I got to see,
um,
Michael and Steve Working together and,
and could just start to plug myself into that process.
And what I kind of think I learnt by that is the kind of freedom with which they
approach the work and the determination to find out absolutely everything that
I've seen can offer to leave no stone unturned and then to a mental,
leave the scene,
leave the moment having left everything on the floor and a and then go out and
enjoy,
enjoy life.
We had it.
I mean,
we had a great time as well,
making this film and that's a,
it's maybe surprises people,
but we put a lot of passion into the days.
Uh,
and we were working at such a pitch.
We have 35 days to shoot the farm.
So we had a total intensity while we were working on the,
on the project,
uh,
people were coming and going,
because of the,
the sort of odyssey nature of it.
So they were parties for people who are arriving,
actors who were arriving,
there were parties for actors who are leaving.
You know,
we were able to,
uh,
to get out there and enjoy each other,
get to know each other.
And that is the kind of family relationship with Steve wanted to build on that
set because uh,
uh,
and the,
and all of that is part of allowing people to go to those places on the days,
in the moment,
in the,
in the heat and whatever.
I think by the end of it,
we were prepared to do anything to tell the story with Steve and,
uh,
and he was a kind of fearless leader who was also prepared to go to any lengths
to tell Solomon the story and how there was just no,
there was no boundary to that.
I think he's a remarkable film maker.
Um,
for that reason.
Just the kind of depth of passion and ability.
Right,
right,
right.
Yes.
I wanted you to talk because I,
I think the day that I arrived,
because we had left apps plantation and because of the character of Mr is Shah,
I think we might've been working differently than was the style that he had
already.
He had already created.
We actually sort of came up with it on,
on the move because,
uh,
if you're gonna lead this very solid foundation that you got it,
it can't be one of those little spare tires that you put on in your car is
leaning to one side.
And so we had to find it in,
in motion in the day.
And it was also something we had no frame of reference for.
Right.
So,
um,
but the,
the reason I came on was that I had seen all of Steve's work when,
when it was happening and uh,
so I said yes before I even knew what he wanted me to do.
Um,
but for me,
he is,
um,
I like working with people that I,
that that I learned something each time out.
You don't learn a lot.
I'm a be honest on movie sets anymore.
It used to be because it was different,
uh,
work ethic.
There was a different aesthetic from,
and people came to their disciplines from a love of it,
from wherever they move from in the world to do it.
Now it's kind of like the Toyota factory moves to town and everybody chooses a
department they want to specialize in because if we go to the places for tax
incentives,
but anyway,
so he is one of those people that not only what was I going to learn something
about myself,
I was going to learn something about the other departments I was going to see,
I was going to be told,
he lets you know what he is seeing the whole time and so,
uh,
again there's no separation between the actor and the director and he's one of
those people that tells you things you can actually activate.
That's,
that is the main problem with directors.
If they do speak at all,
it's usually conceptual.
I'm not going to get any more jobs.
Hi.
But it's like having,
I was just heaven.
It's like having the best piece of music and you're at the top of your form as a
musician and you've got a maestro that is an extension of,
of of you yourself.
I mean it's just,
I've said this,
I would've gone to Kabul and pulled cable for him.
Something that just occurring to me is that I remember when,
when deedee and I were in early conversations with Steve,
he talked about the scene where Solomon is forced to with patsy and it's like
you understood that that seemed contained enormous power.
And it's so remarkable to hear,
you know,
these incredible actors talk about their experiences inside of that framework as
if it was like almost pre,
but somehow he understood that even before that process happened and before the
actors were cast.
And that's,
that's that kind of um,
musicality,
uh,
organic creative PR
evolving process that Alfie was just talking about.
Um,
so we,
I think we all left this experience with just enormous respect and admiration
for Steve.
Oh,
we'd love to talk a little bit about the completed film and then how it's being
received.
And I want to start off with the descendants of,
of Solomon Northup.
Um,
I saw the site that I'm a forensic box up,
put ups basins of solomon.com and if you guys haven't seen that,
you have to check it out.
It's almost like the real,
the real,
real ending of the movie after the credits roll because it's hit the great,
great,
great grandson,
the great,
great,
great granddaughter,
all posting videos.
There's a woman who plays violin like,
like Solomon and their bio's and,
um,
it goes on in their lives.
How have the descendants,
um,
uh,
embrace this movie?
And how has that interaction been?
What,
what's been the feedback
that's sort of been that,
that the best treasurer on,
you know,
in the wake of the film we didn't,
we didn't know what we would find.
I think there's been a Solomon Northup Day in Saratoga Springs every July for
about five years.
And I think last year it was attended by maybe 30 or 35 to send it.
Right.
And it was a deeply intimate,
thoroughly felt,
but,
but local affair.
Um,
and this,
but we had,
we had a thought that if the movie got seen and if it was well received and if
it was discussed that it would be found and that we would find these people that
they would find us.
And it's been,
I mean,
it really,
it's,
it's such a thrill.
I did a Q and a in DC for the Polaris Foundation and during the Q and a,
this woman stood up and I just want to say,
I am the great,
great,
great granddaughter of Sun and read me the lineage and which when I burst out
crying and um,
she had her son with her and it's a,
now we had,
we got Christmas cards and we've gotten emails and congratulations and this
website and the collection of people on it,
the breadth of people,
people of every race,
color,
shade,
Sex,
a age skill.
It's,
it is the most moving and you think this man lived as played by two tall and
look who's here for it.
Um,
but that just keeps coming.
You know,
that's one of the things about this film that is such a gift and it gives us the
possibility to,
uh,
to do,
you know,
jettison so forward into health and wellness as a culture,
as a society.
Because Americans have not wanted to hear about slips.
Slavery,
black people would say,
you know what?
This is the bum me out or I'm going to be so pissed off and why people would
say,
you know,
we didn't have any money.
My people have made,
we didn't own anything or I wasn't there.
It was like nobody want it to look at that and so,
but when you cut off the things that you think are negative,
you also cut off the incredible things that,
that,
that are born out of that,
I mean none of us would be here.
We would not be a super power if we had not had 300 years of forced labor.
And that's a terrible thing.
But it's at,
and we are all related that the genealogical society in d c says that 65% of
Caucasian Americans have significant black blood.
So we try to like parcel up and eat on different sides of the cafeteria and all
that.
I know you all don't but
read by departments.
But the truth is it is a family history.
It is our American family history.
And when we embrace it,
and it wasn't long ago.
And when we embraced that,
we began to understand ourselves and accept ourselves and we begin to understand
each other or a little bit more and to
most of the ills that we have thrown money and you know,
rap sessions and work sessions at since the sentence since the 60s you could
just trace it right back in 2014 the fact of how many incarcerated people are in
this country and how many incarcerated people are black and brown men.
But it traces right back to,
and when you understand where a thing happens,
you,
you approach,
you approach solutions in a different way.
So all of that to say,
and I,
I,
this is an American story.
By that I mean that it's,
it's our history.
It is the,
it is a west African story.
It is a history.
It is a British story.
It's all of that.
Everybody that's involved in that and it informs us right today.
And when we don't,
when we don't recognize that and embrace that,
we lose out,
first of all on all the great things.
But we also will constantly stay off kilter.
Um,
that I,
I just,
I'm hoping that that it is the beginning of being able to,
to talk about solutions.
Yeah.
Well I'd love to thank you.
Then.
I'd love to cut to some questions.
So,
um,
if,
uh,
people can line up for the mic,
but um,
on that note before,
before we do that,
um,
we're,
we're Google.
We love art.
We love great movies.
Thank you Russell Love data.
And if we can go to the slide,
we want to talk a little show actually depict a little,
a little bit around the conversation that,
um,
this movie has really spurred on.
So this is on google.com search trends around the,
the phrase,
uh,
12 years a slave,
but we also bundled in,
um,
things like Solomon,
Northrop and slavery.
Um,
and you can see there's not a lot of conversation happening around that.
And then there's this surge when,
when you release the,
the,
this great picture of that.
That's off the charts.
And if we can go to the next slide.
Um,
this is on youtube.com when you search for the phrase 12 years a slave,
there's over 200,000 search results that come up.
So this is,
um,
uh,
clips that Fox is putting up interviews that,
that you guys are doing,
um,
discussions that are happening,
uh,
in,
in the world.
So you guys are really,
really,
uh,
resonated and encourage this conversation around slavery.
Um,
but that hasn't happened,
um,
in,
in the way that,
that it has now.
So anyway,
thank you man.
MMM [inaudible]
so why don't we cut to two questions.
One,
I just saw the film and I just,
I just have to say it's been absolutely amazing and thank you so much for,
for that.
This is our history.
It's an American history.
Like you said,
was there a certain resolution or something that you all felt that,
oh,
I have to be this or I have to do something,
some kind of takeaway that you all had after the experience of making this film?
What it was a,
I mean,
it's so all encompassing this and the experience.
It was the most extraordinary experiences of my life,
you know,
as a,
as an actor and a,
and outside of being an actor.
Um,
there was just a,
there was a remarkable sense of,
of,
of passion and a responsibility and privilege.
And,
and I feel like the process of making this film and the process of getting out
this idea of,
um,
of,
of engaging with,
with human respect,
you know,
it's something that I think all of us can take into our lives,
into our work communities,
into our,
all the social aspects of our existence.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a very fundamental part of how we exist.
And I think that,
that,
this,
that this film encouraged me to continue to engage with those ideas and to do
things that aren't in my power to,
uh,
to support that.
You know,
we're always kind of pushed to be divided somehow into,
into genders,
into racism,
to religions,
into sexualities and a,
and just let left the kind of pitch it out and fight against each other.
You know,
and I think that,
uh,
but what films like this speak to is,
um,
is the nature of how divisive that is and where that can lead to and,
uh,
and I think we can all engage in our lives to reverse those trends.
Hi.
I just want to say I love you all.
Ms. Woodard.
You're probably one of my favorite actresses in the whole world,
so,
and it's such a privilege,
but I've heard you speak
this particular role.
How difficult did you personally find it?
What did you do to prepare for it?
How did you go about that?
And,
um,
it wasn't difficult at all because
I don't know how to describe it.
When,
when I,
when I take on a role,
um,
first night that,
you know,
not with Steve,
I agreed before I even saw the script abuse you,
but I read it and if while I'm reading,
if by page five,
every time my part comes up,
something happens emotionally on those lines while I read it,
then I'm hooked.
I usually put it away until probably the day before,
maybe two days before I shoot.
But what I started to do is just in my everyday life,
uh,
I see where that person is from the time period,
the type of person just by clues that other what people say about them,
you get ideas about them.
So if I'm at whole foods,
I live in this area,
I'm in whole foods,
you know,
I'll just suddenly start to toy with dialect,
finding that person,
the way they speak and I start to toss in,
you know,
just dialect and so that it becomes natural so I don't have to turn it on.
When I get there I start to work on that person.
The way that they move,
the way that they walk and their sensibilities.
You have to leave behind any evidence of yourself to,
to,
to stand up and flesh out another person.
That's what all of our training is about.
They take you,
take,
you,
take you to a neutral point.
So then you,
so when you start to work,
you build on that.
How I feel about mistress Shaw is absolutely of no importance and especially
it's detrimental to how to do anything about it.
All my responsibility is,
is to find that person's reality.
And I think about
you slowly start to take things on what she would like to do.
How can you,
and I just kind of play that out as I'm moving around.
I don't work on the words.
I think in real life we never know where we're going to say until we say it.
So I want to know as little about what I'm going to say more about
defining who I am,
who be being that person,
standing in that person.
So the one thing that I did with dialect,
I felt terrible because I was so happy to be there that I would just kind of
giddy because it had been working.
You guys were all tired and it was hot man no to Tim had to run up the road and
up the stairs and the first time you ran up we were going to rehearse it.
But I thought,
you know,
you just come up and we'd kind of say just the camera.
He,
he ran up and he was not a breath and he was sweating.
But when he got there,
I was so shocked at,
Oh,
I'm really sorry
you had to run the game.
And I was like,
oh my gosh.
Were like,
so I had to go,
okay,
but,
but it worked because I could not have any awareness of their world or any
feelings about it because,
because she lived in her own kind of space.
So the one thing that I did do was I decided to do work on dialect.
So I try to incorporate because everybody was coming from different places,
like in the Gullah islands off South Carolina,
there's still people that probably speak closer to uh,
the African tongues than before.
And so I knew some Gullah,
I decided that I had come in from that direction.
There in New Orleans is just like a Gumbo.
That's why they have Gumbo.
It's,
you've got rent,
you've got Spanish,
you got west Western it.
So I started to toy with mixing the sounds and also her trying to put on airs to
be what she had seen before.
Tossing in some words,
but not quite having the hang of how they come out.
So just,
just subtly with,
with dialogue.
But,
but that's usually how I put a character together.
Thank you.
As everyone else.
Thank you so much for this movie.
I come from the nine.
It states where I grew up and it's always been something that haunts me,
this subject matter because every time I'm,
I'm more angry.
So the scene where Plat is hanging and slave life was going on behind,
children are playing and I know there's part of that that was instituted
probably they couldn't look at him.
Um,
I wondered how much of that was in the book or was that inspired by
improvisation or the director's input?
It was,
um,
it was a mixture of things really.
The,
uh,
I think,
um,
a lot of it is in the book.
I think the children or something that Steve put in,
if I remember at the,
uh,
on the day,
um,
you know,
I think he was,
it was something Steve was very interested in.
Uh,
you know,
the book is,
so obviously we have to truncate the book a lot.
And what that means is there were certain sequences that had to kind of speak to
why to things then we could put into the film.
Um,
you know,
the nature of the book,
I mean,
you know,
as Jeremy was saying earlier,
it's an extraordinary biography.
It's extraordinary and a,
and there are so many details that we couldn't keep into.
We couldn't put into two hours.
So there were,
there were things that we had to kind of come up with that,
that represented the kind of emotional journey that people were going on in
different ways.
And I think Steve was just trying to find different images that could represent
not only the physical torture,
but also the psychological torture that was,
that was happening and how,
um,
and how that society was kind of,
we're sort of working and was,
and was controlled.
So,
um,
so he used different elements.
I mean,
we,
we tried to make a film that was a very,
very accurate representation of the book.
Um,
and,
and also give more of the scope that the book has that we couldn't necessarily
fit into the,
into the two hours
the institution of slavery has had such,
I like lasting direct impact on American culture,
American life.
And it's something that if we're not always the most informed about,
we're still always kind of remember,
but I also was struck by how many people in the movie involved with the movie.
We're not American.
Um,
but people who grew up surrounded by this reminders of this institution versus
people who kind of heard about it maybe secondhand,
maybe who experienced it in different ways from across the Atlantic are.
Yeah,
I think we will all vary.
I mean,
we're all very connected to this experience,
you know,
in the,
uh,
kind of,
it's just the way that it's that slavery globally worked basically in terms of a
west Africa,
which is where my aunt and my family come from.
Ebo people,
hundreds of thousands of Ibos are taken out of the bite of Benning.
Um,
I was in caliber just before coming over to shoot the film,
which is in the east of Nigeria,
out of slavery museum,
which had a roll call of the number of emails that were taken out about
particular port.
So it was never something that I felt any distance from in that way.
Um,
obviously growing up in London and a,
and the nature of the slave trade and the West indies and how that affected not
only,
uh,
that area,
but then also Britain and the nature of the sort of industrialization of
Britain,
France,
Portugal,
uh,
then into South America.
You know,
I mean the slavery was international and um,
and uh,
and this story is very specifically American,
but then,
but speaks to so many things that are kind of wider than that,
you know,
and it always felt to me correct.
I didn't,
you know,
uh,
there was always a kind of question whether there's,
you can legitimately tell other stories in that way.
And I felt like you can because,
because by definition it's correct that there's an international element to the
story.
I think 95% of the people who made this foam or American,
you know,
but it always felt right to me that there was,
that there was,
there were elements and strong elements of that represented the fact that this
isn't just a,
it wasn't just an American phenomenon.
It's about,
uh,
about people,
about our,
our,
our collective history in Europe and the states and Africa.
To add on to that,
to that question,
just really quickly,
um,
uh,
how has,
how has the movie been received and in places like Nigeria,
Kenya,
Britain,
France?
Well,
I,
it's not out in Africa that,
yeah.
But yeah,
so we don't yet know,
but there's definitely a lot of interest.
Was an interest on online,
a lot of support from what has,
what has been heard from over here and,
and in the UK
it's a number,
it's the number one film in the UK regulations.
Thank you.
Okay,
great.
Thank you up.
Yes.
I just,
something that,
that I remembered while you were talking,
if you guys realize that we were a slave economy longer than we were anything
else,
but yet we deny that.
So that's why we're,
that's why we're off balance.
Thank you.
Um,
and thank you to the cast and the producers for we're making this great film.
good luck.
This awards season.
We know that there's a lot of great things to come and we want to thank you for
spending time with us at Google.
I like,
thank you.
Thank you so much.
[inaudible].